se regrouper pour être plus fort et plus
efficace et l'idée même du concept de
kloster bonjour jean philippe version
bonjour médium dont vous êtes le délégué
général de martinique développement
c'est cette structure qui dépendent de
la collectivité territoriale de martinez
qui dont le but est d'aider au
développement des entreprises et du
territoire jean philippe version le
cluster sera décliné à toutes les sauces
au palais des congrès de madiana demain
car il faut encore en faire la promotion
mais c'est quoi un cluster merci de nous
inviter un cluster ou comment vous le
définir je vais prendre une situation
qui est une des citations favorites de
la présidence de martine gay de pommes à
la manette torpille qui dit souvent que
seul on va plus vite ensemble on va plus
loin et je pense que ça traduit bien en
fait l'esprit en fin de l'année un mythe
cluster le cluster c'est un regroupement
d'entreprises souvent de petite taille
qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens de
pouvoir se positionner à l'export ou
améliorer leur capacité à négocier avec
des fournisseurs et donc qui se
réunissent parfois pour un temps donné
pour créer de la valeur
être plus forts ensemble et se projeter
et créer de la valeur ajoutée
c'est pas juste une appellation à
consonance anglo-saxonne et qu'on glisse
ici et là pour faire branché
alors souvent en fait on essaie de
mettre des concepts sur des réalités
mais il y a des goûts des regroupements
d'entreprises des collaborations on va
parler de collaboration de coopération
d'entreprise il ya des entreprises qui
coopèrent et de saveurs pas clusters et
donc mais bon ces deux concepts qui
traduit une réalité et nous ce qui nous
importe en fait c'est cette réalité de
coopération être plus forts ensemble et
clusters se retrouve dans quels secteurs
tous sans exception il n'ya pas de
secteur qu'ils ne puissent pas permettre
et favoriser la collaboration
aujourd'hui en martinique il y a déjà
des initiatives qui ont été prises par
les entreprises dans différents secteurs
l'agroalimentaire le service à la
personne
le tourisme l'hôtellerie il y a vraiment
eu vraiment des de réelles opportunités
pour nos entreprises se positionner dans
ces dynamiques nyalas est en martinique
exactement et nagoya alimentaire n'est
dit le transport les services à la
personne le logement social le tourisme
le tourisme
de luxe et comment décide-t-on de
devenir un cluster qui doit initier
cette démarche alors la dynamique de
clusters il faut bien comprendre que ce
doit venir des entreprises
aujourd'hui il y à un environnement
favorable à la création de clusters en
martinique la collectivité territoriale
à valider des dispositifs notamment de
soutien financier à la création des
clusters martinique développement
aujourd'hui à des conseillers
spécialisés pour accompagner la création
de clusters
cependant l'initiative doit venir des
entreprises et c'est en ce sens que nous
souhaitons informer les entreprises ce
vendredi pour qu'elles sachent qu'il y a
des possibilités pour elle de
s'organiser mais c'est évidemment une
émanation des entreprises mais
finalement qu'est le poids de klosters
et on peut voir ce que 1 kloster
regroupement de petites moyennes très
petites entreprises comme comme un
interlocuteur valable sur certains
thèmes sur certains sujets ça fait du
lobbying alors je suis me permettez je
prendrai un exemple pour expliciter en
fait ce que peut être un cluster et la
capacité ce que ce qu'il peut créer
nous avons connus récemment en fait des
catastrophes naturelles avec des besoins
de reconstruction ont noté peut imaginer
qu'à saint martin saint barthélémy l'île
de la dominique par exemple on aurait
très bien pu imaginer que des
électriciens des plombiers les
charpentiers martiniquais se regroupent
des abris dans des exercices en voilà
pour former une force de négociation met
un peu de sous pour par exemple financer
un commercial pour aller négocier des
marchés soit individuellement ça il
aurait été très compliqué pour elle de
réaliser ensemble
elle aurait pu constituer une force une
capacité de négociation pour pouvoir
obtenir des marchés
est ce que par exemple si moi je suis
boulanger si mon collègue jimmy et lui
on va dire réparateurs automobiles et si
par exemple classique était là dans son
studio il ya quelques instants était
dans un autre secteur d'activité nous
pourrions former un cluster par exemple
mutualiser des moyens comme le
secrétariat des choses comme ça alors
la mutualisation effectivement peut se
faire d'un dynamique logistique mais il
est vrai que dans les clusters
généralement on retrouve des entreprises
d'une même filière par exemple tout à
l'heure j'ai pris l'exemple en fête de
l'artisanat mais sur le champ de la
création souvent autre exemple des
entreprises peuvent se regrouper
aujourd'hui pour constituer une force de
négociation avec un fournisseur
c'est ce qui se passe par exemple dans
dans le secteur de la pharmacie des
pharmaciens qui se réunissent pour des
centrales d'achat par exemple cc c'est
un peu cette logique
aujourd hui mais il ne s'appelle pas
kloster voilà mais aujourd'hui le ce
qu'on appelle le sourcing salle et la
capacité à identifier en fait des
sources d'approvisionnement constitue un
enjeu de création de valeur ajoutée au
sein des entreprises et une entreprise
souvent bon c'est qu'aujourd'hui que la
chine produit
c'est l'un de deux décès d'une des zones
ont produit le plus un autre poète
martiniquais aurait plus ou moins des
difficultés à aller trouver un
fournisseur en chine mais on pourrait
très bien imaginer que des entreprises
se regroupent sur un secteur d'activité
identifiés pour pouvoir constituer une
force pour pouvoir constituer du volume
et donc derrière pouvoir être ému
incapacité de négocier de meilleurs
tarifs et donc derrière améliorer leurs
marges et créer de la valeur
alors comment peut-on quantifier
l'impact de clusters duc leicester
comment quantifier son action alors il y
à quelques indicateurs qui sont très
symptomatique bon le site l'indicateur
le plus simple déjà ces 2,2 pour en
mesurer le chiffre d'affaires que génère
le cluster mais là où on voit
véritablement l'impact c'est quand on
mesure le chiffre d'affaires que se font
entre les membres du cluster et puis il
ya bien sûr des indes et alors et on
voit bien ce qu'on mesure souvent on se
rencontre souvent que le chi la
progression du chiffre d'affaires
l'entreprise qui sont intégrés dans un
cluster est plus importante que des
entreprises du même secteur qui ne sont
pas intégrés dans ce cluster parce qu'en
définitive le cluster créé une dynamique
qui se traduit par la création de valeur
de la création de richesse ça peut être
également un regroupement de
l'entreprise qui sont concurrentes
ce serait une façon de s'observer de
regarder comment on bouge
alors le l'un des critères importants
dans la création de clusters c'est la
confiance
et alors c est nous en sommes conscients
parce que la propension naturelle de
d'entreprise de très petite taille sur
un marché fermé c'est justement c'est de
se regarder en chiens de faïence et de
se dire bon moi je veux prendre ses
parts de marché mais je ne veux surtout
pas qu'il m'apprenne le cluster accentue
les ambitions ensemble plutôt que de
rester sur le marché martiniquais on
peut envisager de se positionner sur
d'autres marchés
une cependant pendant le k2 il est
acquis le cluster du tourisme vous
retrouvez dans ce cluster des hôtels des
résidences de tourisme des gîtes qui a
priori sont des activités qui cible les
mêmes clients qui sont concurrentes mais
qui aujourd'hui se regroupent parce
qu'elles ont bien compris que il est
plus important de valoriser la
destination martinique pour accroître le
nombre de visiteurs et de touristes qui
viennent sur le territoire sachant que
si le nombre de visiteurs augmente
chacun va en tirer un bénéfice il
connaît les exemples par exemple
d'entreprise qui ont qui ont vraiment pu
se tirer leur épingle du jeu grâce aux à
des clusters parce qu'il a des clusters
parce qu'il ya les premiers testeurs
sont apparus en martinique il ya déjà
quelques années
dès les années 2010 en fait le premier
cluster c'est le cluster innova gros qui
qui a été accompagnée de
l'agroalimentaire le secteur
agroalimentaire et qui a été accompagné
par par le parme
si je peux aussi l'agroalimentaire
régional de l'agroalimentaire excusez
moi le pôle agroalimentaire de la
martinique
si je peux citer une entreprise par
exemple les shows que la chocolaterie
nausea qui fait partie de ceux de ce
groupement ces entreprises se sont
réunis pour développer les process faire
preuve d'innovation pour créer de
nouveaux produits est aujourd'hui passée
les entreprises qui en font partie
continuent leur développement se
positionne à l'export et je pense en
fait créé de la valeur
concernant ces clusters est-ce que vous
avez déjà identifié des secteurs pour
lequel vous ferez tout pour qu'on puisse
se regrouper à crier parce que il n'a
que sept pour l'instant mais dans quel
secteur vous verrez par exemple et bien
fait de l'émergence de poster alors
comme je vous le disais précédemment je
pense qu'il ya un potentiel
indifféremment de secteurs d'activité
l'important c'est d'eux qu'il y ait une
volonté et c'est en ce sens en fait que
nous organiser cette conférence nous
souhaitons informer des possibilités qui
sont offertes aux entreprises ont amusé
quand le secteur sur lequel vous verrez
vous voyez bien que ce serait une bonne
chose si on va prendre un secteur qui
est très connue aujourd'hui sur le
numérique à la martinique où on a des
entreprises qui sont très dynamiques
il y a un vrai potentiel en termes de
développement parce que notre territoire
se caractérise par des idées des
entrepreneurs déjà aidé des start-up
heures qui sont ambitieux qui qui se
positionnent sur des champs innovant et
qui de mon point de vue en réel
potentiel en fait à l'export et au non
en martinique développement notre
ambition c'est de pouvoir les
accompagner pour qu'il puisse rayonner
au delà même de
du territoire menti ni quel est le rôle
des organismes de formation des
pépinières d'entreprises
lorsque certaines personnes avec 10
projets viennent les voir
est-ce que déjà vous vous intégrer cette
notion fait en sorte que ce soit
intégrer cette notion de deux testeurs
dans à ce stade même de la création de
l'entreprise
ces structures comme vous venez de citer
constituent des partenaires importants
dans l'émergence en fait de ces
classeurs pour ce que parce qu'elle
constitue sans vouloir utiliser de
termes trop technique un écosystème en
fait
kiki un environnement favorable au
développement de ces dynamiques et de
ses entreprises
aujourd'hui martinique développement
dans son rôle des agences de
développement économique de la
martinique a pour ambition en fait de
travailler avec l'ensemble de ses
partenaires d'identifier toutes les
possibilités qui sont à la disposition
des entrepreneurs martinique pour
pouvoir leur apporter cette information
pour qu'ils puissent en fait faire le
saut qualitatif qui leur permettra
d'accentuer leur développement et dans
les écoles qu'on en parle déjà de ces
notions de clusters je pense que des
étudiants aujourd'hui ils sont déjà
directement là dedans alors il y à des
dynamiques aujourd'hui qui sont et qui
sont initiées par le rectorat par des
opérateurs comme au niveau des
associations d'entreprises mais selon
nous il y a il y a lieu en de doper
encore c'est dynamique parce que lens
l'entrepreneuriat il y à la nécessité en
fait régulièrement en fait de
d'alimenter en fait ce terreau
d'entrepreneurs étant entendu que la
martinique se caractérise par un taux de
création d'entreprises qui à l'échelle
nationale n'a rien à rougir avec
beaucoup de régions de l'hexagone
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
jean philippe version rappelle que vous
êtes délégué général de martinique
entreprises et que demain il y aura
cette rencontre au palais des congrès de
madiana sur les clusters coopérer pour
développer son entreprise merci d'avoir
avec le monde merci nous avons